شهد العقدان الماضيان رواجا لنظريه
الاعجاز العلمي في القران حجر الاساس الذي
استند عليه اصحاب هذا الطرح اكثر من الف
ايه قرانيه تم الربط بين الكثير منها
وبينما اثبته العلم التجريبي الحديث من
اكتشافات فاثار ذلك حفيظه بعض المتخصصين
في العلوم الشرعيه وعلماء الطبيعه فما
حدود المقبول والمرفوض في مساله الاعجاز
العلمي للقران
[موسيقى]
ما المقصود بمفهوم الاعجاز العلمي هل هي
جاءت من المعجزه بمعنى ان فيها نوع من
التحدي نعم يعني التحدي هنا ياتي بسفق
القران الكريم بالاشاره الى كم هائل من
حقائق الوجود من حولنا قبل ان يصل الانسان
اذا معرفه شيء منها
14 سنه هذا هو الاعجاز الكتاب عقيده
وعباده واخلاق ومعاملات واذا ناقشنا كل
قضيه من هذه القضايا لوجدنا ان فيها من
الحقائق
القاطعه ما يشهد للقران الكريم بانه لا
يمكن ان يكون صناعه بشريه بل هو كلام الله
الخالق التفسير العلمي للقران مثل التفسير
العلمي للسنه اذا التزم من يقول بهما
بالضوابط العلميه الدقيقه فانه يحقق هدفه
في تثبيت مبدا الوحدانيه وصدق النبوه
وعندما ننظر الى القران نجد حشدا هائلا من
الايات الكونيه الفلكيه على سبيل المثال
في سوره البقره نجد قول الله تعالى ان في
خلق السماوات والارض واختلاف الليل
والنهار والفلك التي تجري في البحر بما
ينفع الناس الى ان قال لايات لقوم يعقلون
لاحظ كلمه يعقلون فكان اللب الانسان وهو
خالص عقله هو الذي سيدرك عظمه هذه الايات
وهل المفهوم الذي ذكره علماء العقيده عن
المعجزه او الاعجاز ينطبق على ما تضمنته
الايات القرانيه من اشارات كونيه عندما
اريد ان اتحدث عن اعجاز او اي اعجاز
يكون لدينا ضبط او ارتباط بهذا المصطلح
اذا هناك ثلاثه اركان
لمصطلح المعجزه الاول انه في يعني امر غير
عادي في تحدي للاخرين والشيء الثالث ان
يعجز الاخرين عن
الاجابه المعجزه تعريفها يجب ان نحتربه
هذا شيء والشيء الثاني ان يكون التحدي
بصوره او عشر صور او اكثر نعم نعم فانا
برايي
جهاز مصطلح يعني غير متطابق مع هذه الشروط
لكن ليس معنى ذلك ليس هناك كلام علمي في
القران
الكتب السماويه الاخرى قد فقدت بالكامل
والموجود عنها صناعه بشريه تعبر عن ما بقي
في اذهان الناس من هذه الرسالات القديمه
ان كانت اليهوديه او النصرانيه ولا نجد
يعني شيء من الحق العلمي الذي يمتلئ به
صبحات القران الكريم
علمي بدل من الاعجاز العلمي التفسير شيء
اخر غير الاعجاز انا برايي هناك في القران
حق تشريعي هناك حق علمي هناك حق عن الغيوب
ايضا الشرع والقران استفاد منه استفاد منه
في عده امور هذا الحق العلمي شيل الاول
البناء النفسي للمسلم الشيء الثاني البناء
العقلي المسلم الشيء الثالث التدليل على
وحده المخلوقات الشيء الرابع التنديل على
وحدانيه الخالق الشيء الخامس تدليل على
امكانيه البعث
السادس ايضا ما يتعلق بصفات الله
الايه من اهم ايات الاعجاز العلمي والسماء
بينها بايد وان لموسعون لان الفلكيين
كانوا يؤمنون بثبات الكون نظرا لان علاقات
الاجرام السماويه في داخل مجره واحده
ثابته ولكن عندما توسعت اجهزتهم في النظر
الى الكون لاحظوا ان المجرات تتباعد عن
بعضها البعض وهذا الذي جعل كثير من
العلماء الغرب يغيرون افكارهم المعاديه
للامام بالله سبحانه وتعالى الى شيء من
النظر بموضوعيه وبحكمه وجعل العديد من
العلماء الغربي يسلمون بهذه الايه
[موسيقى]
اولا عدم الاحاطه بالاقوال التفسيريه
الثاني الجزم بان هذا المعنى هو ذاته لا
يوجد معنى اخر الثالث تحميل الايه ما لا
تحتمل لان يدخل الى القران بمقررات سابقه
ليجعل القران مجرد تابع له لا مرشد وهذه
له ان يظن ان التفسير العلمي هو السبيل
الوحيد
للدعوه الى الله بطرر من الدعوه الى
الاسلام على النحو الذي يسلكه انصار
الاعجاز العلمي في القران اذا اذا اعتشفنا
في قضيه التفسير العلمي ممكن لانه بعض
النظريات العلميه ما انتهت الى يقين يعني
ما زالت في اطار التطور والجدي فيها انا
براي الربط بكلمه الاجاز العلمي انا بعتقد
فيها خطا هاي هل المطلوب ان بعد كل اكتشاف
علمي ان نبحث عن ايه في القران تساند هذا
الاكتشاف يعني الاصل ان اوظف اي حق علمي
يصل اليه الانسان في تفسير الاشاره له في
كتاب الله او فسنه رسوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم بدون تكلف وبلوره